okay so how'd you get into rockefeller
the way i got into rockefeller was um
omiya
i always say this and i never worked
with her per se but omielly macintosh
she ran
um jay-z's fan club fan fam okay
her sister darren mcintosh worked at
rockefeller they from brooklyn they all
came up with jay and all of them
what i did was is like i was the
youngest person in the mail room
so i was like i think 17 or 18 at the
time
i was 17 going on 18 when i got in the
mail room so the rest of the mail room
is like we got a few rappers in there
you know what i'm saying we gotta yeah
everybody's like 25 and older but i'm
the young guy so when i come upstairs
like i'm i'm always i've always had a
personality to help and it's been
it's been at my my uh and my advantage
and my detriment yeah
me too but like so i'm i'm the kid who's
like
i'm so inquisitive because i've seen the
movie backstage and now like classic
when i seen backstage oh i'm seeing i'm
in the build i see tata walking in one
day i see lenny s i'm seeing all these
people part of that movie was shot in my
hometown in phoenix so i and i was at
that show when i was like
so i was like i was at that concert
right right so i went to see it with my
friends in the movies
but like i'm like i'm asking everybody
like how can i like how can i help and
omi's like yo you know
it's a fan club so they shipping out
t-shirts they shipping out cds
whatever that people shout out to the
days of fan clubs too fan club's the
real fan
right you know what i mean you really
subscribe and get real dope [ __ ] you
know what i'm saying absolutely
you got to write a letter to get in the
field club so i would help with shipping
so i would help with shipping only used
to give me tickets to go to like j
concerts and [ __ ] like that and then
i built a rapport with like i was on the
floors that i had was the royalty
department and murder inc was on that
floor
because it was a universal building and
then um you had uh what was the other
floors
i had to bring a lot of inner office
because people wasn't using email like
that right so it's in an office mail
so it'd be like only be like yo take
this second floor yeah take this to my
sister
at rockefeller right now so i'll go up
the rockefeller go up there
and i had built a rapport with them to
where i had after i got
fired from their mailroom and i was
trying to figure out my next steps i was
working at a little sneaker store on my
hood and all that [ __ ] i quit that after
i've tried i'm like i need to do this
music [ __ ]
i just hit people up like yo can i i
didn't know what an internship was but i
dropped out of high school in ninth
grade so i didn't know i didn't know
what career even meant
right so i was just like yo can i help i
just helped and i just sat around in the
middle room she was like the intern
without even knowing you was the intern
i was just sitting in the office and
then i i was sitting in the office just
sitting there doing whatever
go get the food go get the sneakers go
get whatever and then i got
an internship and then the internship
ran a little bit
the beanie calling his mom [ __ ] that
happened within that
and um then i ended up getting an
assistant in our position you know i was
working under my man big face gary
wow i mean he just started a podcast but
um he was one of damon biggs
homies that he grew up with from um
downtown manhattan and [ __ ]
the the days of interning and like
really like
really just like looking down and
working because that's how i got into it
i worked for free for two years at the
radio station before i got like actually
on the radio oh yeah absolutely you
gotta put your work in but that [ __ ] is
gone man well yeah no these kids because
we're like entitlement generation is in
full effect no super entitlement and i
mean
everybody needs to get money or they got
to see immediate payoff or they're not
they're like yo
yeah that [ __ ] is crazy that's why i
don't be like like i my kids
[ __ ] they get [ __ ] but then i'll be like
man i ain't giving y'all like [ __ ] that
i gotta work for that like it is this
[ __ ] is an incentive
your allowance is an incentivized
business right allowance is a business
for me
like my business manager has to cut my
kids allowance so it's like oh you
you're not cleaning up you're not
cleaning up uh you ain't cleaning your
room or you didn't take out the garbage
and now your allowance is not enough for
you to get them pairs of sneakers so now
you want me to go buy you a pair of
sneakers now ain't doing that [ __ ] [ __ ]
that
[ __ ] that no you gotta work for yourself